Film Courage: What thoughts do you have for
people who are having trouble getting their
scripts out there and getting seen, getting
read.
What advice do you have?
Writer/Director/Actor/Producer, Barney Cheng:
I’m having the same problem.
I think the problem is finding the right person
to send it to.
If your script is about a mystery you’re
not going to sending it to a romantic comedy
company.
Each of our stories is so specific and so
authentic to our experiences, you just have
to find the right match.
Once you find the right match then it’s
great.
I think the homework (your work) in addition
to finishing the story and getting the story
in the best shape possible the next step is
to find the right company or the person to
send it to so the frustration probably comes
from that, sending it to the wrong people,
not doing the homework to send to the right
people.
Film Courage: Are you in this position now
or you’re working on it right now?
Barney: Right now I am focusing on finishing
my project.
I feel like it’s not good to send anything
out that is not ready.
That’s another thing that a lot of people
(a mistake that people make) that they send
out stuff that is not ready.
You have one chance so you better make sure
that the project is in amazing shape before
sending it out to people who are going to
consider your project.
I am focusing on my feature film right now
with the script.
When it’s ready then I will send it out.
Film Courage: Do you have an idea of when
it will be ready?
Barney: I give myself this rewriting process
by the end of September so I have about three
months to finish rewriting the script and
then probably a couple of rewrites before
I send it out so this is my second rewrite.
Film Courage: Will you give this to anyone
else to look over?
Barney: I will send it to…I have a group
of people that I trust.
I will send it to a handful of people that
I trust who will give me truthful, authentic
advice and feedback.
Don’t give it to people, your family members
who always say good things about it.
Don’t give it to actors who want to be in
the film, you know what I mean?
Just make sure that those people have no conflict
or any kind of vested interest in being in
the project (whatever).
Someone you trust, someone who knows what
they are talking about.
I have about five or six people like that
who would give me their authentic, real, advice
and feedback that are constructive.
Film Courage: Are they also writers?
Barney: Some writers, some actors, some producers.
Question for the viewers: Which is harder,
writing the screenplay or getting someone
to read it?